[Musik]
guten tag am 26.11.2008 10 stand die
welt der wissenschaft unter schock und
nicht nur sie denn an diesem tag
verkündete ein chinesischer forscher die
ersten genetisch edierten menschen der
geschichte geschaffen zu haben
im rahmen einer künstlichen befruchtung
sei das erbgut von zwillingen so
verändert worden dass die neugeborenen
mädchen fortan immun gegen hiv seien
würden eine sensation ein tabubruch
vielleicht sogar ein frevel und nur ein
beispiel für die enormen möglichkeiten
die sich mit den fortschritten der
gentechnik der zeit ergeben
ich bin sehr froh über diesen extrem
relevanten themen kreis mit zwei
ausgewiesenen experten sprechen zu
können dem paläogenetiker svante pääbo
der mit seinem leipziger team das genom
des neandertalers rekonstruiert hat
sowie der zürcher bio ethikerin und
philosophie war jener herzlich
willkommen die frau war jener wie haben
sie denn diese grenzüberschreitung
diesen tabubruch wahrgenommen wie haben
sie davon erfahren und vor allem wie
schätzen sie ihn ein preis gibt es noch
einige fragen
ein aufruhr ein schock
sie haben ein forscherleben der
entzifferung des genoms des menschen und
seiner vorfahren gewidmet wenigen sie
diese maßnahme war menschen genetisch in
der keimbahn zu manipulieren
ja ich denke ich war genauso geschockt
wie fast alle anderen lieder von gehört
haben
natürlich hat man fast befürchtet oder
erwartet dass irgendwo auf der welt
irgendetwas man sowas passiert und jetzt
ist es wahrscheinlich dann passiert habe
ich nehme sozusagen hoffnung von der
fakt dass alle eigentlich dagegen sind
das sogar die uni in changchun in china
wo das angeblich passiert testen abstand
nehmen und ist es auch
man kann ja sagen ein schock ich
verstehe dass andererseits sie deuten es
an hast doch nach der wahrnehmung vieler
nur noch eine frage der zeit bis
irgendjemand voranpreschen würde und
sagen das was technisch möglich ist das
mache ich jetzt auch was natürlich ein
problem ein allgemein ende und das ist
auch eine technologie die nicht sehr
aufwendig ist wenn man die
labortechnische voraussetzungen haben
es ist nicht so wie eine atombombe zu
bauen die möglichkeiten sind da man
wusste dass es gibt ein rechtlichen
rahmen und er gibt es den überhaupt wie
ist denn das gibt es global verbindliche
regeln regeln für den umgang mit dem
menschlichen genom
zu lifedirekt du doch keine sanktionen
die man jetzt eben könnte
sie sagt es ja die technologie ist da
sie verglichen das selbst mit der
atombombe oder dem atom spaltung jetzt
könnte man sagen dafür gibt es
internationale behörden die global
überwachen was in diesem bereich
geschieht warum gibt es das nicht für
genetische manipulation
das ist vielleicht eine gute frage ich
denke es gibt auch derjenige konzerns
vielleicht sogar über was wir denken was
welcher typ unseren experimenten sollte
man verbieten oder nicht es gibt ja für
einkommen über biologische waffen zum
beispiel wo es mehr von den konzernen es
gibt als solche sachen wie wir jetzt
besprechen
trotzdem behauptet wird es hätte einen
vorteil für den gewinn und es wird ja
oft eine formulierung bemüht da spiele
jemand gott und das hat schon eine
wertung in sich wer das nicht richtiger
zu sagen da spielt jemand evolution weil
zum beispiel die immunität die diese
beiden kinder nun in sich tragen ist
eine die auch natürlich vorkommt die
also auch in der evolution schon
entstanden ist klingt doch ganz anders
da spielt jemand evolution als gott oder
ja ich will doppel dossier vorsichtig
sein ich denke wie verstehen so
unglaublich wenig von der evolution
ja es gibt menschen die eine relation
einer verlust von datei von dieses gehen
die jetzt musikschule tragen und die
sind resistent gegen hiv-infektionen das
ist wahrscheinlich erstmal nicht genau
dieselbe der lektion die man ja
eingefügt habe würde ich verordnet und
wir wissen auch dass dieses gegen
irgendjemanden wurde in der evolution
und gibt bei menschenaffen und menschen
es hat sicherlich auch irgendeine
funktion die wir noch nicht verstehen
also ich denke wir überschätzen uns
unglaublich wie denken wir können die
revolutionäre die verbessern und
vorantreiben
es ist ja schon ein eingriff der in der
weise enorm ist dass diese kinder
sollten sie selber kinder haben dieses
gehen jetzt weiter tragen geben
weitergeben werden es gibt eine gefahr
dass man die komplexität nicht über
schaut welche gefahren sehen sie denn
insgesamt noch bei solch einem eingriff
jetzt ist dieser tabubruch in china
geschehen einem land das sehr gut
überwacht ist bei dem auch der staat
weiß was die wissenschaftler tun für wie
glaubwürdig halten sie denn die
bekenntnisse des chinesischen staates
von diesem experiment nichts oder wenig
gewusst zu haben und es ist ja auch
gerne verhindert zu haben
die fragen sich kann ich eigentlich
nicht einschätzen
vielleicht in der schweiz sind wir auch
ein bisschen wie gut meine bewacht ist
in china so was ich verstanden habe
gerüchteweise hat diese vorher sich
beurlaubt und zu sagen dass außerhalb
oder seine neue tätigkeit gemacht so ich
weiß nicht könnte man sogar sagen wir
sollten diesen man dankbar sein weil er
durch diesen tabubruch jetzt ein thema
erzeugt hat dass wir intensiver
diskutieren
als wir sonst diskutiert hätten dass das
aus der latenz in das explizite gezogen
hat die sorgen diese diskussion ist
stattgefunden
wir haben eigentlich vereinbarungen und
jetzt geht man hin und machen aus
dagegen hat und wieso so wie wir jetzt
beide ein wort verwendet das nicht
hellhörig werden lässt das wort wie wer
ist denn eigentlich dieses wir ist dass
die gemeinschaft der forscher sind dass
die staaten ist das eine
weltgemeinschaft die überhaupt ein
er ist oder besteht das problem hier
gerade darin dass es dieses einheitliche
wir gar nicht gibt
ich habe das gefühl dass in diesem
gebiet gibt es eigentlich ein konsens
zwischen forschung und gesellschaft und
gesetz gebe ländern starten und ich
denke das andere für sich das
vorbildlich voran getrieben von den
erfinderinnen und ist mit je einem
verdiener ist zum beispiel jemals ein
paar kleine von den mittel finden sind
von dieser technologien und sie lieben
wird sehr viel von ihrer zeit für diese
ethische diskussion findet die
technologie die diesen eingriff möglich
gemacht hat ist relativ jung erst einige
jahre alt ja ist christa und bin hier
öffnet sich ein möglichkeitsraum der
eigentlich schwer zu übersehen ist wie
das genau funktioniert mit dieser gen
schwere kristall das schauen wir uns in
einem kurzen film an
und so funktionierts christa zuerst wird
ein dna abschnitt bestimmt an dem die
gehen schere ansetzen soll die schere
wird dann so programmiert dass sie genau
diesen abschnitt findet hat sie ihn
gefunden wird der strang
durchgeschnitten und ein natürlicher
reparaturmechanismus verbindet die
beiden stränge das gehen wird
funktionsunfähig aber das bad gut bleibt
intakt so kann ein defektes gen
ausgeschaltet werden
mit dem gleichen verfahren können gene
aber auch ersetzt werden
eine große chance dieser neuen forschung
die vererbung einer krankheit kann so
verhindert werden
ja also eine gen schere die an etwas
einsetzte was welche auch im modell
haben
der stoff aus dem wir alle gemacht sind
das genetische grundlage des menschen
das genom also da wird an gewissen
stellen ein schnitt vollzogen etwas
eliminiert was auch wieder hin zu
gesetzt werden kann verstehe ich das
richtig ja so diese christel schneidet
dann ein oder zwei sternen
wenn man das nur so macht zeigt man eine
religion wie wir sagen ein stück wild
verloren wir hören und dann das das ist
anlegern gehen zum beispiel
auszuschalten und das ist was mit dieser
sozial 5 gehen in china jetzt gemacht
wurde was man auch machen kern ist dass
man in diesem prozess gibt mal auf
synthetische dna stücke ging und im
labor synthetisiert hat dazu wir eine
etwas andere krebsarten und die werden
dann verwendet um diesen beruf zu
reparieren und so kann man eine neue
mutation hinein fühlen man kann eine
solche buchstaben in den genetischen
code und führen mit einem anderen
ersetzt davon gibt es hier zur
menschlichen genommen drei milliarden
wenn ich richtig informiert bin
unglaublich komplex wir kennen die
wechselwirkungen nicht der aufschrei ist
jetzt groß am menschlichen genug
tatsächlich wird das aber schon bei
tieren und auch bei pflanzen gemacht
darüber schaut man die wechselwirkungen
ja auch nicht oder
[Musik]
yes we can defence space und was
besonders beunruhigt da ist nicht
unbedingt die wechselwirkung mit anderen
gegenden man kann ja sagen wenn ich eine
mutation traditionen furchtbare
krankheit führen in meinem leben wenn
ich tastan vereins zu den nicht
kernkraft eine mutation weiß ich dass
diese mutation 50 nicht in menschen
aber das problem ist diese hier bewährt
haben die oft tollwut effekte dass diese
schere programmieren wir um dort zu
schneiden aber es gibt eben drei
milliarden solche buchstaben im genom
und wir wissen von experimenten ins
allen tieren dass man oft dann schnitte
bekommen an anderen stellen die dann
auch verwendet werden und die effekte
vom dies und wissen wir eben nicht
und das ist sicher auch bei diesen
zwillingen jetzt passiert und das ist zu
sagen was mich am meisten wohnungen
würde also ein meer des wissens
einerseits aber auch einen ozean des
unwissens der dahinter liegt das nicht
als laie ein wenig verstört eine
verständnis frage ist einerseits ist es
so und sie schreiben das auch an ihrem
wunderbaren buch wenn man das genom
eines individuums sieht kann man so viel
gar nicht über dieses individuum sagen
wie es aussieht wie sich verhalten wird
welche eigenheiten das hat andererseits
scheint es möglich durch sehr gezielte
einschnitte sehr viel an einem wesen zu
verändern also einerseits eine blindheit
was das gesamte genom angeht
andererseits die spezifische fähigkeit
sehr wirkungsvoll zu greifen wie erklärt
man diesen scheinbaren widerspruch ist
so ein mann hat enorme fortschritte
gemacht in den letzten 30 jahren in
denen das man assoziationen ständig
zwischen sollen wir menschen mit einem
gewisse krankheiten oder andere ohne und
sucht genetische assoziationen
was sieht in genau was haben die
menschen gemeinsam an dieser krankheit
leiden
im unterschied zu den anderen sodann
verstehen und in manchmal findet man
dann ein einziges gehen
die antwort wird beispielsweise dieses
hiv immunisierung es gebe genug dem
heißen soll durchaus sorgen
krankheiten die viele
mein blutdruck diabetes
ja ja das vielleicht bist du ein ruf zum
beispiel für besucher noch sehr viele
gene
das ist nicht nur ein positionen die man
drehen kann so wusste ich jetzt hin
die frage einerseits wissen wir sehr
wenig einerseits wissen wir spekulieren
da willst du so werden wir aber den
anderen weg gehen und nicht von der
krankheit zu einem genommen und jetzt
sondern wir schauen uns einfach das
genom abend sorgen was kann ich jetzt
sagen wissen in bildung krankheits
neigung verhalten aussehen
dann sind wir unglaublich schlecht aber
sogar sachen wie hautfarbe oder ikonen
werden zu 70 prozent korrekt vorher
zahlen aber ich sagte gerade malaria
malaria wäre dann einfach wo man sagen
wird vielleicht wissen wir doch wo man
schnippen muss und das ist ja eine
krankheit von der mehrere hundert
millionen vielleicht sogar milliarden
menschen betroffen sind
ist es da nicht geradezu eine pflicht
ein wenig zu schnippeln
allerdings muss diese interessante
grenze was wir bei tieren erlaubnis
fähig sind und bei menschen nicht mehr
auf die werden wir noch eingehen bleiben
wir mal kurz noch bei menschlichen genom
sie frau war jener haben wie viele
andere menschen mittlerweile teile ihres
genoms ermitteln lassen
und sie sagen sogar ich habe es in die
öffentlichkeit gestellt ich hab es der
forschung öffentlich einsehbar gegeben
keinerlei bedenken dass da etwas über
sie heraus käme was sie vielleicht
lieber für sich behalten würden
aber sie würden
und die art der information ist ja wie
sie sagen wir sind ein bisschen schnee
blind wenn wir so ein individuelles
genom sehen man weiß gar nicht so viel
sie hätten vielleicht gar nicht sagen
können das cover jener braune haare hat
und die und die größe hat das kann man
alles nicht sehen und sie sagen auch von
sich selber und sie sind ein mensch der
sehr viel über genau weiß wollten sie
das nicht wissen haben es bisher auch
nicht getan
ja das ist nicht ganz behaupten sie
sicher bist tatsächlich auch aus vielen
aspekten nicht angeschaut meinte nur es
ist auch so dass für viele sachen die
mich vielleicht beunruhigen würden wir
krankheiten die ich bekommen könnte
haben wir sehr wenige aussagekraft von
was wir wissen und für manchen sachen
die vielleicht sehr unangenehm ist da
und wir für alzheimer wenn man homo zu
gut ist über diese varianten also beide
kopien sowohl von mutter als vater
dieses risiko varianten an hat man
tatsächlich viel höhere risiko dafür
aber wir können gar nichts tun dann
gegen so warum soll ich das wissen
es heißt auch nicht dass ich jemals als
zeigen wir bekommen habe was kann ich
machen will kann zu sorgen nichts machen
um das volk zu beugen aber ich kann
niemals ein beispiel nennen von einer
person einer sehr bekannten angelina
jolie die von sich weiß dass sie an
brustkrebs wahrscheinlichkeit hatte auf
ihrem grund ihrer genetischen anlagen
die sich beide brüste abnehmen ließ weil
sie sagte sie könnte es vor ihren
kindern nicht verantworten man kann
etwas tun aufgrund dieser information
und gewisse menschen tun es weil sie es
für geradezu ihre pflicht halten
präventiv einzugreifen
sie sind sehr interessant es gibt diesen
philosophen imperativ erkenne dich
selbst erst genom scheint dann schon
eine art spiegel der selbsterkenntnis
werden zu können was man mehr
informationen über sich hat als man
vielleicht vertragen und für sich selbst
auch verarbeiten kann eine information
aus ihrem genehmigen könnte hp
wahrscheinlich
sehr gut nutzen er könnte nämlich sagen
wieviel neandertaler in die ihnen steckt
wie viel näher an der tat in jedem von
uns steckt das kann man schon sehen
angenommen oder genau sowas will
herausgefunden haben ist das werden ihre
genetische wurzeln außerhalb afrika ist
dann abends trauermusik ungefähr 1 bis 2
prozent des genoms kommen von metallen
und zwar unterschiedliche stücke
gewöhnlich bei unterschiedlichen
menschen so wahrscheinlich tatsächlich
sie und sie unterschiedliche sagt man so
ja nicht wirklich sorgen 1 bis 2
vielleicht hat man den erkenntnisse
darüber was diese speziellen sequenz die
meisten noch in sich tragen für
funktionale für wirksame wirkungen
zeitigt wir lernen mehr und mehr darüber
fast jeden monat erscheint es dazu viele
davon hat tatsächlich mit risiko oder
schutz gegen krankheiten zu tun das ist
auch weil viel kommt von der
medizinische genetik
es gibt varianten ziemlich häufig sind
hinaus sind zum beispiel hohen risiko
für typ-2-diabetes n typ von
zuckerkrankheit in einem hohen auto
bekommt es gibt also viele hautkrankheit
und zum beispiel ist das risiko rielle
sachen aber auch sachen die der kreation
oder neigung sondern auch zum beispiel
es gibt auch varianten die tatsächlich
vorteilhaft sind viele immer immunsystem
gibt eine variante die von einem cousin
von der tollen aussehen kommt im team
wird die es erlaubt am hohen höhen
ladung zu leben wo wenig sauerstoff ist
gibt in der atmosphäre
aber wenn ich jetzt meine fantasie
spielen lassen mit christa könnte man
sagen ich will einen sehr
leistungsfähigen 10.000 meter läufer dem
schnitzel ich dieses gehen für die blut
sauerstoff regulation in dem anderen der
nicht zuckerkrank werden soll dem
schneide ich das andere dar ein spiel
nicht da oder ist das eine perspektive
die sich öffnen könnte da haben wir
genau alle diese vorbehalte die wir
jetzt besprochen
nicht dass wir sozusagen nicht wissen
was für andere effekte wie im genom
haben dass sie auch nicht wissen wie
funktioniert diese varianten wenn man
dann in einen anderen umwelt leben
wir wissen ja dass zusagen krankheiten
oder andere effekte von genen ist ein
zusammenspiel zwischen diesen
genetischen varianten und der umwelt in
dem wir leben
wieso ist eigentlich eine genetische
variante zu 25 für sein häufigkeiten
gekommen die zu diabetes führt heute
eine gute spekulation habe ich dazu
und das ist das was diese variante
fürchte ja zur problem in einem
gesellschaft wo wir fast zuviel erst in
unserem ganzen leben in eine andere
situation wo wir periode hungen sind
wahrscheinlich dieselbe varianten sehr
vorteilhaft so sollten wir das selbst
verändern wir wissen nicht was unsere
zukunft ist das hätte schon was von
watts spielen in diesem sinne wenn man
so will
wenn man ihre forschungen sehen dann ist
das einerseits der handwerklich es ist
andererseits sehr biologisch medizinisch
ist es andererseits aber auch an
hantieren mit extrem großen zahlen
mengen mit wahrscheinlichkeiten mit
milliarden von daten
frau werner es gibt ja eine art connex
eine verbindung zwischen diesen
genetischen fortschritten und big data
mit der fähigkeit daten mehr und mehr zu
verarbeiten
sehen sie da die große zusammenkunft die
neue sprünge ermöglichen würde
einerseits big data und andererseits das
genom wissen
[Musik]
erziehung umwelt ist ein fantastisches
beispiel für solch einen gelungenen
forschungsschritt ist das was sie
geleistet haben
rp wo sie haben mit ihrem team das genom
des neandertalers weitgehend
rekonstruiert sie sind dafür
preisgekrönt worden vieler weise auch
von der körber-stiftung und wie sie das
gemacht hat und wie das in ihrem labor
aussieht das schauen wir uns auch in
einem kleinen film an
in fundstätten wie dieser höhle fördern
die wissenschaftler hunderte von knochen
fragmenten zu tage das rohmaterial zur
erforschung des neandertaler erbguts von
der steinzeithöhle gelangt das wertvolle
knochenmaterial in die reinraum labors
von svante pääbo
hier beginnt mit dem heraustrennen
möglicher erbgut teile aus den knochen
die eigentliche arbeit der beginn eines
sehr mühevollen vorhabens denn in vielen
dieser proben ist nur sehr wenig oder
gar keine brauchbare neandertaler dna
mehr erhalten
doch im laufe der jahre konnte das team
den genetischen schatz aus der
vergangenheit zutage fördern
möglich wird dies erst durch die
aufarbeitung der erbgut fragmente aus
den knochen
dazu werden die winzigen dna bruchstücke
zunächst vervielfältigt und dann wie ein
puzzle zusammen geführt
mit dieser hightech gelang in den labors
eine weitere wissenschaftliche sensation
die ein neues licht auch auf uns heute
lebende menschen wirft aus afrika
kommend treffen die modernen menschen
vor rund 50.000 jahren zunächst in
vorderasien auf die neandertaler und
mischen sich mit ihnen die gemeinsame
nachkommen bilden vorfahren heutiger
europäer
es gibt so vieles was einen daran
fasziniert aber was zunächst ja auch
zutage tritt durch den schlüssigen des
genoms gibt es eine neue weise die
geschichte der menschheit als menschheit
und ihre ausbreitung zu schreiben ist
das richtig haben eine neue generation
davon wie der mensch sich über die welt
ausgebreitet hat die hierauf von dieses
1 nicht gut war schon da wie der moderne
menschen verbessert habe von der
untersuchung und jetzt lebenden menschen
nicht was dazu gekommen durch diese
arbeiten ist dann dass wir verstehen was
passierte mit dem früheren menschen
folgen wären die tolle in europa die
ihren verwandten in aussehen dass die
nicht völlig ausgestorben sind das die
haben sich gemischt bis diese
neuankömmlinge aus afrika und leben dann
mal weiter in menschen
heute wenn man so will und das szenario
von dem wir sprechen ist etwa 50.000
jahre 70.000 jahre her und da gibt es
eine hypothese sie nehmen sieht das
nahost szenario in dem die neandertaler
und das was wir heute die modernen
menschen bei deren vorläufer sind sich
getroffen haben und sich nicht nur
gekriegt haben sondern sie haben mich
auch gemischt sie haben nachkommen
erzeugt weil wir finden das alle
menschen außerhalb auf diesen beitrag
auch in bereichen wo nina und die tolle
gegeben habe in china in papua neuguinea
daran ist zu sagen die idee dass man hat
sie früh gemischt wenn man aus afrika
kommt und wir wissen dass es nie an die
tolle lebten und hunderte von tausenden
von jahren im mittleren osten so
wahrscheinlich ist eine mischung da
stattgefunden und die afrikanische
moderne menschen haben dann diesem
beitrag mit sich geführt wir wissen
inzwischen aber auch dass man hat sich
auch später gemischt wir sehen dann
sogar schlechte hinweise darauf in
europa zum beispiel aber jeder sie sind
jetzt griechen unterrichten an der eth
sie sind damit europäerin und sie hätten
eine chance die mehr miteinander thaler
gen in sich zu tragen als beispielsweise
ein afrikaner
das ist richtig und was hier an dieser
forschung noch für mich hervortritt der
begriff der rasse der mag falsch und
nicht gebräuchlich seien aber der der
population dass gewisse population ein
erkennbares genetisches muster haben den
gibt es doch schon
zur smx jetzt gibt es zum beispiel in
amerika waren im fernsehen schaut ein
unternehmen das bietet an das genom zu
entschlüsseln und dann sieht man
menschen die sagen ich habe
herausgefunden dass ich zu 13% native
american also indianer denn das hat
meine perspektive auch nicht selbst
vollkommen verändert ich muss sagen ich
bin da ein bisschen das berührt mich
unheimlich weil man hat das gefühl dass
eine art von rassismus durch die
hintertür wieder eingeführt wird
ich bin ja sozusagen essentiell indianer
das hat doch auch gefahren diesen
kurzschluss zu wagen wir waren eine gute
und eine schlechte aspekt davon
vielleicht nicht es zeigt auch wie
häufig man sich gemischt habe in der
vergangenheit diese vorstellung von
einer reinen raste die erst vor kurzem
sich die nicht hat ist offensichtlich
falsch es gibt ja so viele
untersuchungen an tausende von skeletten
den ort wo man diese techniken verwenden
um bevölkerungsbewegung über den letzten
10.000 ja heute vorwiegend da findet man
viel mehr als wir dachten an das heißt
würde ich auch sagen das sagen
die gene sind zu sagen sehr hoch
gepuscht heutzutage ja wieso wo ist
meine genetische geschichte eigentlich
so interessant für meine identität auf
unglaubliche ja und das verstehe ich
nicht ganz ich ich komme aus nordeuropa
ich wurde nach griechenland und gucken
auf akropolis und fühle mich sehr
verbunden sorge das ist der ursprung und
meine kultur ruhe von uns architektur
von der demokratie
ich fühle mich sehr berührt aber ich
weiß schon dass keiner von meinen blüten
chromosomen jeweils in den alpen
griechenland wohl aber für mich als
individuum und mein empfinden und mir
ist verwendet das gar nicht wie wichtig
griechenlands und der alte griechen sind
zeit finde ich das für meine identität
sind eigentlich meine gene nicht sehr
wichtige kulturelle geschichte
das ist wirklich diesen kurzschluss mein
genom ist meine identität zu vermeiden
viele scheinen den heute wieder
attraktiver zu finden als früher
politische gefahr
[Musik]
was ich es auch so sagen finde ist dass
es gibt sehr viele die einsicht in die
von der genomforschung gekommen ist die
nicht trübe kommen alle diese
unterschiede zwischen populationen ist
unterschieden häufigkeiten von varianten
nicht die häufigkeit milch zu trinken zu
können ist höher in nordeuropa sind
gehen tolerieren europa wenn man so
sagen jetzt anhand von den daten wir
haben sondern gesamte genome von 100
afrika vergleichen mit 100 leuten oder
aussehen
das ist der grösste zu sorgen
unterschied dass wir haben es uns
geschichtlich wie viele varianten denken
sie ist eine absolute unterschied also
tut ein typ von unterschied gewinnt
vielleicht 100 interessent haben das in
afrika dort präsenter europot umgekehrt
gibt keine einzige wir finden zwölf
verschiedenen behinderungen 99 prozent
haben eine variante in afrika
interessenten und das kommt nichts rüber
denn was zu sagen war eine art
verwandten denken und genetische
unterschiede das was absolut ist alles
anders ist sozialen unterschiede gibt es
einfach nicht es gibt aber eine antwort
auf das was wir alle sind wir sind
menschen genetisch homo sapiens sapiens
sie haben das neandertal geben um
weitgehend rekonstruiert kann man denn
vielleicht doch ein bisschen genauer mit
dem finger darauf zeigen wo der schritt
zu den fähigkeiten die wir jetzt hatten
haben im vergleich zu den der anteil an
genetisch vollzieht gibt es da
einflugschneisen die sagen da passiert
etwas was für unsere geistige für unsere
mentale entwicklung entscheidend ist das
ist traum aus darüber rauszufinden in
der zukunft mit hilfe von björn beton
das ist teil des projektes sogar
finanziert ist und in der stiftung domes
stiftung
es gibt bereiche in unsere genome in
europa und asien wo man sorgen würde
statistische warten was wir dann weiter
von lern der total haben und wie es
verteilt ist aber wir finden das nicht
da scheint es also dass man selektiv hat
in der vergangenheit selektiert gegen
diese weiter von den anderen und wir
können eine list ein katalog machen
jetzt und varianten die alle menschen
heute tragen die wir kennen oder 99,9
prozent von allen ist den lernenden wir
haben das aber nichts
diese katalog ist nichts zu groß es ist
so 30.000 veränderungen oder ihn genau
so wir können alle diese fänden am
nachmittag im computer durchgucken das
problem ist eben wir verstehen gar
nichts was bedeutet aber natürlich
versuchen wir jetzt da einige
veränderungen die proteine verändert
vielleicht anzufügen wir sind wo wir
wissen was sie vielleicht tun die zu
untersuchen
eben mit chris sparkassen versuchen
diese veränderungen in menschlichen
stammzellen reinzubringen zellen
stammzellen
wir machen keine babys daraus aber wir
die vielen dann diese zellen wie dann
die neandertaler ähnlich und zum stand
haben für eingehen zu lassen sondern zum
beispiel im gewebe kultur und versuchen
zu untersuchen die funktionieren das
sind einerseits fasziniert ein bisschen
unheimlich ein kollege von ihnen hat
auch aufgrund der forschung die sie
gemacht haben gesagt geben sie mir 30
millionen dollar
und ich baue ihnen schöpfe ihnen kreiere
einen neuen wären dann thaler frau war
jena ist das eine gute eine furchtbare
oder vielleicht sogar eine sinnvolle
idee
[Musik]
die problematik claim the project wie
sie jeder hat er überhaupt was gesagt
oder war das gros sprecher
es ist nicht einmal problematisch ist
und wir zutrauen und vertretbaren würde
ich sagen
ethisch wie wir gesagt haben ich habe
eine folie diskutiert soll man
krankheiten vielleicht heidel es zu
jedem menschen zeugen aus
wissenschaftliche neugier oder sowas
dass wir überhaupt nichts kontaktieren
das andere ist dass es technisch
eigentlich schon wirklich ist sondern
wir werden wir dann 30.000 veränderungen
einfügen müssten wir sind meilenweit weg
davon heutzutage dass du machen wir
haben eben diese oft holgi defekts die
dann sich hoch addieren bewiesen auch
sagen es gibt einen großen teil des
genoms sind für ein drittel des genoms
das repetitive ist das bestimmt auf den
musikfans sind die ähnlich sind
diesen teil des genoms beim neandertaler
zum beispiel kennen wir nicht genau weil
wir haben nur kurze bruchstücke hat nie
wisse nicht vom welche kopie von diesen
rapids repetitiven sequenzen die kommen
sie wissen habe laut dieser repetitiven
teilen des genommen auch wichtig ist für
wie unsere zellen und unsere körper
funktionieren
so werden eine ganz genaue liste normen
über das neandertal genau das ist
technisch und ehrte unmöglich und 0
sensationsmache menschen sind ja in
vieler hinsicht seltsame wesen sie sind
auch deswegen seltsam weil sie ethisch
eine absolute grenze zwischen dem mensch
und alles anderen lebendigen ziehen das
was wir besprechen wird an tieren
derzeit gemacht sogar höher entwickelten
tieren sogar an affen und wir haben
diese effekte wenn ich sie richtig
verstehe kaum mehr im griff wie ist das
eigentlich philosophisch wie wird diese
absolute grenze gerechtfertigt wenn die
risikoabschätzung doch eigentlich das
richtige argument sein soll
absolut
[Musik]
wir führen hier ist man eindruck ein
extrem europäisches gespräch in dem
sinne dass wir die probleme die gefahren
die tabus in den fokus stellen andere
erdteile sind da sehr viel
optimistischer utopischer die sagen das
ist doch wunderbar für die biodiversität
für den schutz von tieren die vom
aussterben bedroht sind von pflanzen die
vom aussterben bedroht sind
all das können wir durch diese techniken
in gewisser weise schützen indem wir es
reparieren
das heißt es öffnet sich nicht noch ein
problem korruption sondern auch die
möglichkeit sehr viel zu retten und zu
schützen was derzeit vor der zerstörung
bedroht ist jetzt nicht ganz
er ist nicht reagiere von denen wir
mittlerweile das genom haben dass ich es
vielleicht in 80 jahren nicht mehr geben
und dann hätte man die in gewisser weise
gerettet und bewahrt
ich bin zu sagen einig dass wir bedrohte
tiere haben die wo sehr viel in diesen
wenigen vorhanden ist macht es sehr viel
zu sagen ein zufrieden für die zukunft
wo man vielleicht technologien haben
individuum zu schaffen
wenn einmal ein eine art ausgestorben
ist und wir haben keine zusagen zellen
die lebensfähig sind
dann sind die endgültig ausgestorben
diese technologien wird nicht dazu
führen dass man die in einem richtigen
zähne wieder herbringen kann man könnte
dann kann man sich vorstellen weltkriegs
bei technologie einzelner eigenschaften
wieder pläne so wenn eine sehr berühmte
den ethik professorin post und jetzt
sagt man er will man zurück züchten
heißt das nicht dass sie wirklich an
mammute sorgen würde vielleicht würde
eine elefant seien die behauptet maximum
und das ist doch irgendwas gerade ich
kann dazu schon interessiert oder ist
vielmehr eine frage dieses evolutionäre
geschehen auch das genetisch geschehen
ist millionen milliarden jahre lang auf
seinem weg zu uns happy book ist es eine
falsche einschätzung zu sagen das geht
derzeit wenn wir über die evolution als
revolution nachdenken an einem ganz
neuen punkt an einem wendepunkt sind in
dem der mensch das übernimmt was
milliarden jahren dann so genannten
natürlich ablief ich würde sagen es ist
natürlich das erste mal dass man sich
vorstellen kann könnte dass wir ändern
uns in genua
aber wir werden da eine sehr begrenzte
und wahrscheinlich einfältige weise tun
so viel denken was mitmachen revolution
läuft ja immer weiter jedes baby ist
geboren ist hat 50 bis 150 neue
mutationen dort werde von von dem motto
noch vom vater kommt so die revolution
läuft weiter was immer wir machen was
immer wieder basteln aber die
fortschritte allein der letzten 30 jahre
die sich ja vielleicht doch akkumulieren
mit manchen anderen technischen
möglichkeiten
die könnten auch dazu führen dass wir
sagen wir sind hier an einem wendepunkt
vielleicht den 26 11 erreicht und wir
können noch nicht einmal abschätzen wo
wird in 20 jahren sein werden wenn man
die fortschritte der letzten jahre sieht
[Musik]
und das kandertal aber viermal länger
auf der erde als die modernen menschen
es bisher sind könnte es sein dass meine
500 jahren aufgrund verschiedener
genetischer modifikation auf 13 zurück
so schaut die wir auf den neandertaler
zurückschauen sein kognitiv
eingeschränktes krankes letztlich dummes
wissen sie was ich meine
dass wir in einem schritt zu einer
menschen sind der auf uns so
zurückschaut baby auf dem wandertag
eines tages wird man sich jetzt schaue
ich weiß das ist doch dass aufgrund von
genetischen eingefügten veränderungen
unserer genom ist aber natürlich nimmt
man zurückdenken auf uns als sehr
rückständig zukunft ist das ein
fortschritt den sie sich wünschen
ich hoffe sehr dass dieses gespräch ein
kleiner schritt auf diesem gedanken
vollen fortschritts weg war ich danke
ihnen sehr dass sie heute hier waren hp
die frau bei jena
vielen vielen dank
[Musik]